Yeah.
Nancy, I didn't bring my wallet.
You going to buy
me a cup of joe?
I got it.
The amazing thing to me, though,
about the University of Arizona
is the comprehensive
nature of the scholarship.
So that the cardiologists
can go across campus and work
with the psychologists
and the brain
people is really
pretty extraordinary.
And at the same time, we're
working with the chemists, who
are helping us design the drug.
I mean, that's amazing.
You don't find that
just at any university,
that level of collaboration.
In fact, you find is
so rarely, they can't
deal with it at the NIH, right?
That's exactly right.
And your students are
going to get-- in post-docs
get such experiences.
Your post-docs working
with cardiologists,
that doesn't happen very often.
No.
And to your credit,
Meredith, you're
the person who initially
straddled the barriers
and said, I'm
interested in both.
Let's do some work.
And that's the most fun
type of science to do
is when you get to
do bigger things.
And nobody else is doing it.
Like you said, the NIH,
it's an important area,
but they're like,
where do we put it?
Right.
They don't know
what to do with it.
Yeah.
Hopefully they'll fund it again.
The next one, yeah.
The next one, right?
Yeah, yeah.
Well, and I mean, you've got
at it with your students.
The ability to learn
from people who
think completely differently
from you improves your science,
don't you think?
I mean, you just
expand your horizons
because you're
dealing with people
who aren't like all the
people you've dealt with.
Did you ever notice that
everyone we're working with
is a woman?
That's true.
I mean, that's pretty unique.
Yeah.
Pretty exciting.
We have one male
collaborator at NIH.
But everybody else on this
team pretty much is female.
That's unique.
This is a cool place to
work because of that.
Yes.
Yeah.
And for me, it's just
probably the most
fun I've ever had in my
life in terms of science.
Instead of just always
testing mice and rats,
actually getting
to work with humans
and making a
difference possibly.
It's going to be
really exciting for me.
Also I'm always struck that
whenever we having a meeting
together, we start
laughing and joking.
Our staff doesn't think
it's very funny, though.
They're all sitting
there like stone faced,
like, they think we're weird.
They don't laugh or cry, right?
But it's ultimately good
role modeling, right,
that we're having
fun doing what we do.
It's not a job.
Yeah.
Right?
Well, it is a job,
but it's a fun job.
It's a great job, yeah.
Yeah.
I wouldn't want to
do anything else.
Exactly.
You're very, very laser focused.
You don't have the luxury
of looking too far afield
and collaborating
too far afield.
And I think that's
something that we
need to give young
scientists, whether it's
a post-docs or a junior
faculty, credit and opportunity
to look far afield.
Because when I started and you
started, you did psychology
or you did cardiology
or medicine,
and you didn't think
about anything else other
than that for neuroscience.
So now how do we actually reward
faculty for collaborating?
It's not all about just
being first author.
It's about being second author.
Team science.
So we have to reward team
science in ways that we
haven't done in the past.
Imagine if we could actually
decrease the number of patients
who experience these cognitive
impairments after surgery
and don't go through delirium.
And then beyond that, if
we can decrease the risk
for them developing
Alzheimer's disease,
that would be the
apex of my career.
There's no question about it.
And also, I think if we can find
that this drug doesn't just--
It's not just for heart failure
patients, but aging patients,
anybody who has
surgery and who's older
and has the chance of
cognitive impairment.
It might be effective in a
number of different patients.
I mean, that would
just be stunning
if actually we can bend that
curve of cognitive decline.
Yeah.
Well, as a clinical
trialist, I think
about a lot of clinical
trials I've been involved in
and drugs that we've proved
work in heart disease.
Doctors don't prescribe
the drugs often.
It's not taken up.
You know, well,
it's one more drug.
Really how good is it?
How much better?
Even if people are dying
at a much lower rate
in the clinical trial,
it takes a long time
to convince the community.
I think if this drug worked,
convincing the community would
not be hard.
People understand cognitive
dysfunction and memory
impairment and how
horrible it is.
But here is a condition where
there's no therapy at all.
If we had something, this would
be prescribed rapidly, I think,
and taken up very rapidly.
And having that kind
of impact, to me,
after watching how slow medicine
evolves, would be really--
Yeah, yeah.
A joy.
It'd be really exciting.
Yeah.
I agree.
Well, it's been a great ride.
Here to success.
That's right.
Let's keep it going.
Here's to the next grant.
That's right.